so the babylon b is hugely successful
because it's great it's one of the few
remaining amusing sites on the internet
it's really smart so of course big tech
hates it and is trying to censor it and
prevent people from reading it seth
dylan is the ceo of the babylon b is a
very successful businessman he probably
spends all his time just trying to keep
his voice from being stifled seth thanks
so much for coming on so
what is i know you've been involved in
these battles probably every day for
months now what are the attempts now to
shut you guys down
where do i begin uh well i mean it
starts with misinformation right i mean
we've been fact checked to death uh over
and over again it started out with this
fact check about cnn purchasing an
industrial industrial-sized washing
machine so they could spin the news
before publication you know when it's
just been on and on and on from there we
get fact-checked well that wasn't real
wasn't real that was a fake story
believe it or not
um so you know the
basically the social networks have been
using these fact checkers to you know
try to is like under the guise of like
trying to control misinformation um it's
politically motivated has been the whole
time
and we're seeing like right now we're
seeing a drastic drop in traffic a
decline a steady decline over the course
of time it started really
around the election last year uh well
leading into the 2020 election
uh and it's just been this steady
decline rapid decline we used to drive
most of our traffic through facebook we
now drive very little of our traffic
through facebook uh our articles that
used to go crazy viral you repost them
now they get like barely any shares at
all i joked recently like one of the
articles that we shared it got it
reached 11 people we have over a million
people in our audience it reached 11
people we could reach more people if we
printed it out and like nailed it to
like a telephone pole in a small town
i mean facebook now or the social media
companies are specifically going against
satire like they're basically saying
humor is no longer allowed and they're
saying it explicitly
yeah well okay so they've made new rules
right they have new rules that they're
rolling out they've got this new policy
satire is allowed they're going to allow
satire but there's a catch you can't
punch down no punching down is allowed
so they've got this new thing uh and how
you define punch down punching down i
mean look it's like they have all these
protected things these sacred cows that
they don't want you to joke about they
want to control your speech and control
what you joke about and i think it's the
most condescending thing ever i mean
imagine thinking to yourself i can't
joke about those people they're beneath
me i mean how condescending is that to
have that thought go through your head
we're not allowed to joke about women
because joking about women would be
considered punching down it would be
hate speech under the guise of satire i
don't think women are beneath me so i
reject the whole premise that you know
there's this that there's it's even
possible to really punch down at people
who aren't beneath me to begin with but
they just perpetuate those stereotypes
by enforcing rules like this and it's
really just aimed at uh curbing and
silencing and ostracizing satire comedy
and thinkers that they don't like
if you're regulating humor you're i mean
you're kind of east germany at that
point aren't you
oh yeah i mean yeah absolutely look the
putting putting your rulers up that's
the whole point of satire right it's to
it's to punch up it's to speak truth to
power uh you know tyrants don't like
that it's the thing that they hate more
than anything else
so you know the fact that they're coming
out after us we're actually not punching
down we are punching up most the ideas
we go after are progressive ideas
they're popular ideas they're advanced
by celebrities corporations politicians
they're coming from the top down we're
punching back we're punching back we're
not punching down if anybody is fighting
the power it's the babylon b and you
will succeed in the end because you're
smart
and we're rooting for you thanks that's
thanks so much for coming on
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else